certains y voient un eldorado du ballon
rond beaucoup arrivent d'afrique et
espère un premier contrat ça fait un
bail que je me prépare ce voyage j'ai
emprunté un sens interdit
c'était trop cher quand je serai
quelqu'un de haut niveau je vais ramener
les gens que j'ai arrêté
l'équipe des dessous de la
mondialisation en kit et dans plusieurs
clubs de football de thaïlande
l'eldorado se transforme vite en enfer
pour la plupart des joueurs si t'as pas
le visa à l'immigration te prend soin de
mettre en prison il sait pas combien de
temps avant d'être rapatriés
les dessous de la mondialisation c'est
sur public sénat
[Musique]